check this out this is Midtown New York
City Lexington Avenue right by Grand
Central Station this is this weekend and
watch these pramas protesters and again
do not tell me they are not pramas
because there is nobody out there
condemning Hamas and and nobody would
dare condemn Hamas out there check out
these pro- Hamas protesters tearing down
an American flag climbing up on the flag
pole you can see it you'll see that put
the Palestinian flag there oh and note
the police officers watching them do
[Applause]
it
what you saw there were about 30 police
officers watching a man climb the post
rip down the American flag replace it
with the Palestinian flag that is
illegal that is a crime and they let
them do it so either all of those police
officers should be fired for not doing
their job or the police chief is telling
them to not do their job in which case
he should be fired and if he's telling
them not to do their job because he's
getting some message from mayor Adams or
whoever else is on the way up the chain
then they all should be fired but if you
live in New York City you simply have to
know the police will not do their job
there and if they will not stop someone
from climbing up on public property and
desecrating the flag of the United
States what else won't they do what else
when when these crazed lunatics when
they start marching specifically through
Jewish communities which they're doing
in other parts of the world right now
they've been doing it in Montreal
they're doing it in in Australia they've
been doing it in London uh and they
start you know breaking uh Windows of
Jewish stores or whatever it might be
and it won't just be Jewish stores it'll
be it'll be any place that there is any
coexistence or decency when they start
doing that will the police do anything
then what is it that the police are
doing but we live in a society where I
suppose these people you know somehow
the Palestinians are oppressed and
that's somehow is connected to the
oppression of the guy climbing up the
pole so we shouldn't do anything about
him